accompagnerò viene così questo nuovo
video dei parigini reagisce i vostri
video da casa perché giustamente se
passa un po troppo tempo da un video
all'altro i farisei video da casa mi si
riempie un attimo la casella di posta
infatti video di oggi sono perfetto
meraviglioso
[Musica]
così perché taglio e vabbè com'è
possibile
ma com'è possibile nostro vedendola come
jay lane got no vabbè gratis per
insegnare fra bellissima anche la
transizione ma chi chi sei
meriti un miliardo di iscritti
la ragazzina mente incredibile io vado
pazzo per i trick shot comunque a
prescindere
beh vabbè ho nella mia testa mi ero
immaginato un rimbalzo che finiva
direttamente nella lavatrice
non so per quale motivo però vabbè tra
regala complimenti porca vacca
macché ma come come è fatto entrare in
casa roba del genere che poveri ragazzi
ma di che parliamo
ma poi perché ma tipul simulato nov
appena sto malissimo e tipo un
simulatore bellissima star o io manco
fuori porca vacca bellissimo aspetta
fuori rivede ti prego ma cos'è geni
pavlov beccava mi piaceva mancati
sigaretta una tv a carol io non ci posso
fare non sa di che cosa parliamo e cioè
oggi hai fatto anche tu non i mosaici
quei cubi di rubik
penso proprio di sì porca vacca
bellissimo ma di grande come che ci fa o
ai ragazzi difficilissimo fa sta roba
ve lo giuro non so se avete visto il
video nel caso andate da rivedere questo
questo qui ragazzi che ho fatto con
giovanni ciao gamer un cutter squadra
dove praticamente c'è questo grandissimo
artista che è lui che mi ha fatto alla
fascia poi cubi di rubik ed è difficile
anche solo fare la scritta è difficile
quindi bravissimo
[Musica]
non prendete a calci le epoche non
prendete a calci e robe in casa non lo
fate non è né non va mai bene è un jack
aco come sa è un k e a me sembrava un
jack ok bravo questo e un jack queste
jack nobile va come com'è possibile
bravissimo life icato nella manica no
non etica per la manica ma che l'avrei
visto come cioè che all'inizio era un
jack questo non raga non è possibile hai
fatto un taglio di video
eppure non mi sembra abbia fatto un
taglio di video come cacchio è porca
vacca bravo
direction cielo nel 2000 con una con
mille in realtà è fatta tutta ma cos'è
se è uguale a james sei proprio james va
bene
sì questo è il quality content che
voglio grazie
quando torni da una serata e ti dicono
che per fare il latte devo accendere il
fornello da bravo bravo questo sembra
cooking simulator quello che facevo no
no non non si accetta che gli avanti
yeah proprio noi grande è piaciuto lo
stile il movimento è l'espressione era
un point bravissimo comunque ragazzi
questa è la vita possibile a casa a
number three mi ha fatto un po è
effettivamente il pendolo uscirne 10 e
bello ideale della giusta grazie mille
no ragazzi sono veramente a parte gli
scherzi contento che vi condividiate con
voi questi momenti da casa perché un po
mi sento parte della vostra family
quando lo fa quindi le voglio bene a
tutti
passiamo insieme a questo momento mi
raccomando ricordatevi sempre io mi
diverto a casa utilizzato come hashtag
perché molto importante e noi ci stiamo
veramente divertendo su sta roba
cioè almeno io sì tiriamo fuori tutto il
positivo che c'era questa situazione ad
esempio cuocere latte con telecomando io
adesso non cuocio niente spengo il video
beh ragazzi
[Musica]